el embarazo es el período durante el
cual se desarrolla su bebé dentro del
útero
suele durar unas 40 semanas contadas a
partir del primer día de la última
menstruación a grandes rasgos estas 40
semanas se agrupan en tres segmentos
llamados trimestres el tercer trimestre
comienza alrededor de la semana 28 y
dura hasta el parto la mayoría de los
bebés nacen alrededor de las 40 semanas
pero algunos pueden nacer antes o
después de ese momento al principio del
tercer trimestre el bebé también llamado
feto mide más de 30 centímetros desde la
cabeza hasta las nalgas en la semana 32
el bebé está aumentando de peso
rápidamente los ojos del bebé ya pueden
percibir la luz y los párpados se abren
y se cierran los huesos están todavía
blandos pero completamente formados su
bebé puede dar patadas y golpear con
fuerza a las 36 semanas los huesos han
empezado a endurecerse sin embargo los
huesos del cráneo y las uniones entre
ellos permanecen blandos lo que facilita
el paso por el canal de parto
alrededor de este momento el bebé suele
colocarse con la cabeza hacia abajo para
prepararse para el parto al final del
tercer trimestre todos los órganos
incluidos los pulmones están preparados
para funcionar por sí mismos el bebé
baja la pelvis y pueden hacer en
cualquier momento es posible que se
sienta más incómoda durante el tercer
trimestre ya que el crecimiento del bebé
ejerce presión sobre los órganos algunos
de los cambios que puede notar incluyen
dificultad para respirar acidez
estomacal hinchazón en los tobillos los
dedos y la cara senos sensibles que
pueden liberar una sustancia acuosa
previa a la leche llamada calostro el
ombligo sobresale problemas para dormir
hemorroides dolores de parto irregulares
y falsos llamados contracciones de
Braxton hicks y contracciones de parto
regulares y verdaderas
Si tiene alguna pregunta sobre el
desarrollo de su bebé o le preocupa Cómo
se siente hable con su proveedor de
atención médica